so this idea that you have that you
should not give a web series towards
some void that's currently not been
filled out there is that embraced by
other filmmakers or web series directors
and have you met any opposition yes uh
I've been asked if I was a hobby because
I didn't talk about demographics and
sponsorship I talked about story and
audience and working with Emmy winners
and Tony winners and you know I I think
part of the problem with the webseries
community is that a lot of people want
to be pioneers and veterans and this is
not old enough to have veterans this has
not been i wrote for web series in 2004
mondomedia in san francisco paid gig
there are multiple syndication to
newspapers so a newspaper or legal
Washington Post would buy syndication
rights to their animated show to have on
our website is content and that would be
the place that it would show up and that
was the revenue stream so they have
forward to fly me from LA to san
francisco pitch come back and right then
in 2007 i directed one show and produced
another show for super deluxe which was
surreal exco which was turner
entertainment so they had lots and lots
of money it was great they paid us all
it was great i am not a bedroom because
this has it been around long enough for
there to be veterans we're not
pioneering an industry we're just
storytellers that i'm posting stuff
online that's been going on since the
mid-90s what's changed his behavior is
the acceptance that i'm going to watch a
television show on my phone for 45
minutes while i'm at the airport that
wasn't a value that was held by humanity
that wasn't people didn't think algun
i'll just go watch on hulu Oh netflix
has now an original series you can only
watch it on netflix they're going to
make more
like that has been where this is all
headed so this idea of a drama should be
a four-minute episode economy should be
no longer than a three minute episode
and it needs to have something that gum
could sponsor building stories up from
the demographics to me is just like
here's the keys of kingdom now do you
want to use any of them or do you want
to act an emulate an industry that has
been storytellers or going on a
century now because the people with the
money get to make the decisions and the
people who tell stories don't hear you
are you have everything all you need is
money and figure out some way to
do it that's all you need to do why are
you thinking about well who could
sponsor this because you need money well
how can we make a cheaper so we don't
need a sponsor so I can tell the story i
want so i can not have to lead a three
minute thing because the people who say
don't make it longer than three minutes
don't make it longer than five minutes
you know they're looking at the
analytics on youtube go well when do we
lose the audience when do they fall off
who are you are you trying to create a
viral video because now you're wasting
your time no one can create a viral
video if you look at the history of
viral videos something happens it's not
that that just made their put online and
they go viral something have someone
refers to it something mentions it
there's a number of blogs even things
that are in the news now that happened a
month ago now they're a big viral thing
you can't make it happen so why are you
pretending you can why are you
pretending to be a producer that walks
around with my well here's all my
demographic so here's my business plan
and really is that is that what you're
doing about when you were a kid is that
what you're wanting to do when you
wanted a holla you know what I'd love to
tell stories and make movies
would that be great which it was some
way I could it up what if I started
to make all my stories based on
demographics of pleasing the sponsorship
and trying to get a company to say yes
why the would you do that now this
has never happened in history ever we've
never been here before
why it up with all the
that's been filmmakers from you
know the indie thing just go from 87 to
now it's a bit about put it on credit
card get in the film festival get a
distributor to go now all those our
houses are gone the money is not there
the festivals are overwhelmed
with projects it doesn't work anymore
and it's great that Kevin Smith us a
giant audience he can find his way it's
great that Edward Burns has diner and he
can find his way the other thing is do
you ever want your own audience how you
gonna get that you know you're gonna
have to do start with one fan and then
you're only going to have 50 fans just
like everybody else you're going to have
to work to build that up if you want to
be your own thing but if you want to be
an employee for the factory that tells
you what to do that you have to fit in
all these certain little things and do
all this then go do it enjoy
yourself put on your suit hold
up your business degree I just want to
tell stories if that's what you want to
do here's all the freedom in the world
figure it out stop acting like everyone
else because you know what everyone else
is doing the same thing they're all
trying to figure out that what chicks
what girls say about this says
but it's such a waste of time like you
can finally get around all the
why would you make the part of
the process it doesn't need to be and
that's what bugs the crap out of the
webseries roll it's just too many people
on a picture on a red carpet with a
step-and-repeat banner behind them too
many people want another award another
award another gives a about all
that stuff yeah it helps with marketing
so just talking to your audience every
day about your story guess what they
want to hear about they want to hear you
talk about your story that's more
interesting them not all of them not
everybody kept some people just want to
go watch something go away I don't care
who made it I don't care this people
aren't great start don't other people
who made this where did this come from
who that's and to have those people
that's really cool to have to have
somebody in England go I've been going
for a really hard time in my
life and I found your show and it made
me laugh and made me forget about my kid
who sick and made me forget about being
unemployed I'll take that over here more
awards a reviewer saying good
job you know to have someone say who is
not part of an industry your story
affected me I'll take that
you